vous sentez l'activité manuelle arrivée
ou pas là c'est un challenge mais qui
sait même pas comment je vais faire bon
les ballons l'origami les casse-têtes la
poterie la citrouille
mais tu vas nous faire quoi aujourd'hui
lucas un vêtement un tee shirt c'est bon
pour vous je vais fabriquer un tee shirt
je sens les vannes arrivée sur lyokô
évidemment ioukos est pas moi qui
fabrique les vêtements être mes mains
moi et mon frère on design mais on
fabrique pas les vêtements avec nos
mains ça s'est fait dans des usines et
avant d'être fait dans des usines s'est
fait parce qu'on appelle un modéliste
hameau davis c'est le mec qui prend les
moqueurs enfin le schéma café designer
et qui le rend réel en faisant un
prototype à la main et bien aujourd'hui
on va aux délices et croyez moi ça n'a
rien à voir
en réalité je trouve ça assez qui feint
de se lancer dans ce truc là de faire un
t-shirt parce que c'est vrai comme on
achète tous des t-shirts mais ce que
vous savez comment c'est fait un tee
shirt
oui et bien dans ce cas je me trompe
totalement à ma grande surprise il ya
plein de tuto sur le net pour fabriquer
ses vêtements et c'est vrai que c'est un
truc qui montrent de plus en plus
fabriquer ses propres trucs fabriquer sa
crème solaire fabriquer son gel douche
fabriquer son shampoing il ya plein de
judo pour faire ça et c'est très cool
aurait été je trouve ça très bien ce
mouvement de faire ces choses soi-même
et c'est pas si compliqué c'est
compliqué mais c'est plus simple que ce
que vous imaginez tout d'abord passons
au matériel parce que là il y en a on a
pas juste un couteau de merde comme
quand on a fait les citrouilles
j'ai dû l'acheter elles sont est très
mauvaise nous présenter cet ustensile à
la fois cool et angoissant la machine à
coudre
elle est déjà c'est top c'est à dire que
la bobine là le fils passe déjà à tous
les bons endroits etc
j'espère que j'aurai pas de galère parce
que croyez moi c'est ça la partie la
plus relou c'est très très chiant à cet
homme mais l'udc a pas besoin de quoi
par une machine à temps j'arrive yassa
évidemment que c'est des bobines de fil
et des petites est paru très important
les mobility regarde la vidéo
vous connaissez mes l'ucad le et le
coton alors atteint avant ça il ya bien
évidemment tout un attirail géométrie
pour mesurer le tissu avant de découper
et du coup d'aller à la table y compris
le chichon j'ai trouvé une chaîne
youtube incroyable qui s'appelle et nos
super être cas quand même 65 mille
abonnés ce qui est très cool pour ce
qu'ils font enfin georges pensait pas
qu'il y avait une communauté
si grande qui a gardé ce genre de vidéos
là là on s'attaque à une pièce qui est
très simple à savoir un t-shirt mais ils
font des trucs beaucoup plus techniques
comme qu on mette sa moumoute sur sa
veste en jean ou ce genre de truc donc
voilà alors tu te sens vraiment cool
donc merci lots supérette est angoissé
où vous dire qu'il l'a fait lui-même en
vrai moi je trouve ça ouf
pour réaliser ce tee-shirt il vous
faudra un t-shirt à vous qui vous va
bien
vous va bien parce que si vous va mal
vous à les reproduire un tee shirt qui
vous va mal ce qui n'a pas de sens nous
on a utilisé un mètre 10 pour un tee
shirt de taille j'ai quatre mètres 20
pour un tee shirt de taille 12 x l parmi
eux 1 m 10 ça fait ça fait abbas a fait
deux fois la règle c'est je me met à
siffler comme un beauf pas ce que je
fais un truc manuel
ok ce parti c'est très long
[Musique]
ok bon étape une réussie on a réussi à
couper du tissu c'est cool pour
commencer vous plier le tissu en de vous
placer la moitié du t-shirt contre le
pli à huy font un tir de référence alors
écoutez moi j'en ai à ces ankama games
qui me l'envoyer bravons cannes en tout
cas donc il faut plier son tee shirt en
2d l'idée c'est de venir découper tout
autour du t-shirt en laissant de 8 cm
sauf en bas vous voulez c'est 2 cm pour
les vous épinglez pour éviter que ça
bouge et vous venez découper alors là il
faut épingler mec au lavage écoute moi
bien aux supérettes la ville natale si
je me mets une époque dans le dois à mon
gars je fais passer ta vidéo - 18 direct
j'ai hâte qu'on utilise la machine à
coudre j'ai hâte et j'ai peur à la fois
[Musique]
très long je sais pas pourquoi j'ai pas
acheté de ciseaux à tissu là
actuellement la justice des même saison
que vous pour découper vos cartes de
géographie là c'est vraiment la même
chose
[Musique]
ok une fois que vous avez découper votre
dos vous répétez l'opération
du coup vous devriez vous retrouver avec
deux pièces identiques au nom fu le
refaire j'aime pas ce guet-apens qui a
dans les vidéos manuel fait ça ça tu
après une heure qu'il refait là tu leur
fais je veux pas mais qu au je crois que
j'ai réussi à temps casse toi toi les
épingles à la baignoire respect tout
comme lui regardez bien lui ce qu'il a
et maintenant moi ce que j'ai mais ce
passé la coupe du tee shirt qui est pas
là même de base en fait c'est ça je
pense juste en partie l'effet
différemment du mien mais je vois pas ce
que ça peut être d'autres non yes j'ai
une très bonne nouvelle à vous annoncer
j'ai mes deux morceaux qui sont prêts je
sais c'est pas la même forme alors la
suite suppose que s'il va faire léman
j'en ai marre des politiciens de coudre
pour faire 1 devant c'est pas compliqué
vous repositionner le tee shirt vous
repérez la profondeur du col et vous
venez découvrir un arc de cercle ok je
vais prendre celui ci pour le devant
parce que je crois qu'il est un peu
mieux réussi je les gelées geler la
profondeur du colle pas donc là on a mon
col et là-dessus va venir se greffer la
manche pour la manche idem supplié le
tissu vous placez la manche plié en deux
contre le pl et du tissu vous épinglez
c'est plus facile vous et bonne musique
plus facile et ouais tout est dur fléron
tout est dur dit plus tôt vous épinglez
ce sera moins dur c'est plus juste comme
phrase bon du coup j'ai dû couper en
fait une bande de tissu pour faire la
manche je voudrais c'est infernal de
couper du tissu mettez pas au gema
manche soit pas dave tallon chez les -
belge fait la deuxième mais je n'arrive
pas
[Musique]
yes ça on s'en fout à tout jamais là
j'ai mes deux morceaux le devant et là
j'ai le derrière
ici j'ai mes deux manches et j'espère ne
plus jamais coupé de tissus de toute ma
vie et pour le col il faut découper une
bande aussi longue que le tour de colle
plus 10 cm je crois que ça y est j'ai la
bande
s'te plaît mais qu on sort la machine à
couture je te supplie je m'abonne si
c'est le cas vous devriez vous retrouvez
avec un devant un dos demain et une
bande pour le col allez on passe à la
couture oui la coupure la couture le
devant c'est celui qui se passe qu'est
ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se passe
pourquoi j'en ai plus qu à une ou deux
acquittements il est où le deuxième
décès fausses j'ai fait laborde dans le
deuxième j'ai fait la bande dans le
deuxième
non on dirait que c'est fait exprès
tellement cellule de faire ça
j'avais écrit un sketch il se serait
passé ça c'est bon en fait c'est le
derrière qui me manquait du coup je l'
ai refait donc on a les mange la bande
le derrière le devant on est au top mais
avant de suivre la suite du tuto
j'aimerais marquer un truc sur le devant
du tee shirt et pour cent vingt ans à
utiliser la machine à coudre place il ya
problème est que cette machine je ne
saurais pas la réparer on va utiliser ça
c'est un peu comme la poterie pédales et
ça fait comme ça et j'ai une idée design
mec est génial alors attendez faut que
je ne repère pas beaucoup
voilà là faut pas que ça foire je vous
colle pas sur le design mais c'est
maintenant je dois le faire avant de
d'assembler les t-shirts à la sortie
à quoi j'ai pété l'éguille de la machine
l'aiguillé cassé l'aiguillé cassé mais
c'est ma faute c'est parce que josep
appuyé à fond sur la [ __ ] mais
j'aurais dû pour que j'appelle lorraine
j'ai cassé l'éguille de la machine l'écu
et j'ai même pas pu faire le sait de
chanel comment fait la ja et bien ils
ont bien pensé à ça ya forcément une
aiguille de rechange
il ya une aiguille leur chance ouais
mais tu vois ils ont prévu le coup donc
c'est un truc qui peut arriver on va si
si c'est un truc qui peut arriver si si
si ça arrive à tout le monde même aux
professionnels apparemment à toute
personne au bon problème technique je
reviens quand c'est résolu
[Musique]
bon j'ai réussi à remettre le film c'est
de loin le plus gros challenge
en tout cas je veux réussir à faire ce
t-shirt d'une grande marque de luxe
célèbre alors on va réessayer ça cette
fois je vais pas me planter j'avais
oublié par exemple de rabat un truc
lassana enflera bats pour ça tiens voilà
là en fait j'ai eu peur l'afocg chose
alors je vais oser ce parti
le fils est parti le fils est parti
c'est bon pour vous c'est le nombre
d'heures qui s'est écoulé le temps d'un
cadre pour le design tout ce qui est
écriture et sert à ces chao
alors reprenons du tout de notre ami
hippiques et un centimètre sans oublier
de faire un point d'arrêt au début et à
la fin comment faire points d'arrêt une
fois que les épaules sont assemblés en
passant - ok la crise épaules
ok ok ok ok là je blague plus il n'y a
plus aucune blague à partir de
maintenant je sais pas si j'ai vécu
pendant l'heure où vous vous étiez plus
là je vous raconterai pas aller pitié tu
marches [ __ ] de merde
[Musique]
l'aiguillé vient de gaza tu aurais pas
dû insultes et de [ __ ] parra
maintenant je sais comment échanger ça
dure deux secondes vous en faites pas on
n'est plus à ça près je suis devenu un
pro vous savez pas comme je suis devenu
un pro fin pour réparer les conneries
pas pour réussir
attendez attendez ça a marché un peu ça
a marché un peu vous comprenez ça a
marché un hoquet l'autre épaule l'autre
épaule
[Musique]
ok ok ça marche et ça a marché je vais
retourner tee shirt on va voir let's go
et 16 go
waouh elle m'a t elle pas si jamais la
lettre comme c'est parti mon numéro une
on espère que tout va bien se passer et
capa d'aiguilhe qui va se casser et on y
va
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
et voilà tu sais pas c'est nickel
[Musique]
à
ça c'est le revers on s'en bat les
couilles personne verra jamais ça allait
deuxième manche
et voilà les manches ont été cousues et
là du coup il va falloir rassembler tout
le reste et hop c'est parti de nouveau
pour une couture un qui va marcher parce
qu'on a on a trouvé le truc arles a
décidément attention voilà donc là ça a
marché
ça a marché ni cal s'est parfaitement
coup cousue à a bien écouté je mets au
gars qui vient de se passer
ça fait trois ans que j'essaie de faire
en sorte que ça marche ça ne marche pas
la machine ne marche pas chez regarder
le même tu tournes ce qu'on t'a ne vois
que je suis ou là je vais faire un tour
différent bad boys
oh non je contemple ou encore qu'est ce
qui se passe j'ai toujours détesté les
gens qui viennent de haut donc écoute
moi bien bons p'tits potes de lots super
est peu je suis mon propre chiot blanc
de la ok je vais te montrer comment on
fait un t shirt je vais te saigner le
modélisme
[Musique]
j'ose pas vous regarder dans les yeux
c'est comme si j'avais fait une bêtise
et que j'étais obligé de la montrer aux
professeurs je suis désolé franchement
je regrette que cela se soit passé comme
ça là je sais qu'à une partie de
nous-mêmes qui ne sera plus jamais la
même après cette vidéo il ya quelque
chose qui s'est brisée je propose une
pause dans les vidéos activités
manuelles je vais me retirer quelques
temps à la place je gérais méditer c'est
quelqu'un d'autre veut prendre ce
créneau des activités manuelles et être
meilleur que moi qu'ils le fassent ça
peut peut-être en bouleverser certains
cette annonce elle est un peu spontané
violente lettres d'amertume mais c'est
pas grave il faut savoir se retirer
faire une pause au bon moment pour
revenir plus fort alors je le dis
officiellement c'est la fin des vidéos
activités manuelles pendant un moment
tout du moins merci tout de même d'avoir
suivi cette aventure merci tout de même
à hello supérette pour son tuto non pas
merci papa merci j'ai quand même passé
un bon moment du moins toutes les fois
où je parlais à la caméra je crois que
sur trois heures de tournage j'ai parlé
40 minutes à la caméra et pendant 2
heures 20 je parlais seul à essayer de
réparer une machine à bientôt
[Musique]